foreign
if you are in therapy you're probably
wasting your time worst you're probably
doing yourself more harm than good
that's the case that I want to make
today in this segment but first let's
establish some necessary background uh
to begin with
that starts with this recently the hill
published a report telling us what we
already know which is that Americans
love going to therapy according to the
outlet quote the number of Americans
seeking mental health treatment is
almost twice as high as it was two
decades ago reflecting a historic recent
decline in mental health but also an
increase in Virtual care and positive
trends of destigmatization in 2004 just
13 percent of adults said that they had
visited a therapist psychiatrist or
other mental health professional within
the past year according to Gallup
polling in 2022 that number was up to 23
percent
now to put this in perspective in terms
of raw numbers if these percentages are
accurate then somewhere around 60
million adults in this country are in
therapy reading on quote a majority of
psychologists reported seeing more
patients seek help for disorders related
to anxiety depression or stress in 2020
and again in 2021 and 2022 according to
an annual survey from the American
Psychological Association many Health
experts link to uh increased demand to
plummeting mental health during the
pandemic which led to spikes in the
numbers of Americans reporting
depression and anxiety some health
experts think the numbers tell another
story however
one about the success of teletherapy
now it's important to note that success
in this sentence doesn't mean that this
type of therapy has proven effective at
helping people solve their problems it
just means that teletherapy has become
more and more common as therapy
customers find it easy and convenient to
sit in the comfort of their own homes
and attend therapy over Face Time
this is part of what has increased the
uh the demand you know it's what Drive
is driving the increased demand the
article also puts a lot of the blame on
covet
but these are all trends that far
predate coveted and face time in fact I
found an article from the American
Psychological Association noting the
significant increase in Americans
seeking Mental Health Services and that
article is published in 2004 so in 2004
they were already noticing this big
increase in people going to therapy and
now we know compared to 2004 it's
doubled since then
the trends become even more evident when
you break it down generationally the
hill notes that as of 2019 which means
that all these numbers are higher now
37 percent of gen Z had received therapy
35 percent of Millennials and 26 of gen
xers
so it's clear that something like covid
is a relatively minor Factor here
therapy is becoming more and more
popular generation after generation and
these Trends have become have been
observable for decades
which is interesting when you consider
again
the very first sentence of this article
which says the number of Americans
seeking mental health treatment is
almost twice as high as it was two
decades ago reflecting a historic recent
decline in mental health
so it's not just uh the hill noticing
this either I mean the rest of the media
along with our Public Health authorities
also insist that mental health is
declining at a historic rate
well that's a funny thing isn't it
correlation doesn't always mean
causation but still the correlation here
is hard to ignore
over the decades we're told mental
health is getting worse and worse even
though more and more people are going to
therapy each year more people go to
therapy
and yet the problem only gets worse
there's a bit of a chicken and egg
conundrum here of course maybe more
people are going to therapy because
mental health is allegedly so bad you
could always argue
but even then if therapy works if all of
the collective billions that Americans
have spent on therapy was actually money
well spent
then shouldn't we see those benefits
manifest themselves in the culture at
some point
instead we just see more and more people
going to therapy well all the problems
therapy is supposed to fix only continue
to get worse and worse year after year
after year after year
just to use a quick football analogy uh
shortly after the end of the 2022 season
the Baltimore Ravens fired their
strength and conditioning coach by the
name of Steve Saunders he had been in
that job for several years and each year
under his tenure it seemed as though
players were getting injured at an
unusually high rate and the problem only
got worse over time
a rash of injuries plagued the Reagan
the Ravens every year now you might
argue that if players are getting
injured a lot that's all the more reason
to not fire your strength and
conditioning coach
he's got a lot of work to do there's all
the more reason why we need him
just let him do his work
but of course the trend indicates that
whatever Steve Saunders was doing to
help prevent injuries wasn't working
if you have a good strength and
conditioning coach you should find that
player health and fitness is trending up
if it Trends down year after year it
probably means that you need to
seriously revamp your strength and
conditioning department and fire the
people in charge of it
so a similar Point could be made about
the people tasked with ensuring that
mental the mental strength and
conditioning of Americans
we have seen nothing but decline in that
area decade upon decade which probably
means that a whole lot of people in the
mental health industry should be fired
on a macro societal level there simply
is no reason to believe that most of
these people are doing us any good at
all
on the micro level you can see this as
well it's not a coincidence coincidence
that many of the worst and most
dysfunctional people you'll ever meet
have been in therapy for years
now there's no sign that's doing them
any good
that it's prompting any improvements
but they keep at it
reminds you of a morbidly obese person
who's been seeing a dietitian for 15
years
something just isn't working here now
you see the morbidly obese person and
you find out they're seeing a dietitian
you say well that's good that's the kind
of person who needs a dietitian but then
you hear oh I've been going to this guy
for 15 years
okay unless you started at seven
thousand pounds and now you're down to
unless that's the case then clearly
there's a problem with the dietitian
something's not working here
with everything going on in the world
right now you could really use a good
night's sleep I know that I could well
that's why you need to check out Helix
mattress Helix has harnessed years of
extensive mattress expertise to bring
their customers to a truly elevated
sleep experience they just launched
their new Helix Elite the Helix Elite
collection includes six different
mattress models each tailored for
specific sleep positions and firmness
preferences I've had my Helix for years
now I absolutely love it night after
night I sleep like a sweet sweet baby
and I want the same for you Helix has a
sleep quiz that matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you because why would you
want to sleep on a mattress that was
made for somebody else go to
helixsleep.com Walsh and take their
two-minute sleep quiz to find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type their flexible payment plans make
it so that a great night's sleep is
never far away for a limited time Helix
is giving you 20 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
take advantage of this amazing offer at
helixsleep.com Walsh with Helix better
sleep starts now as many of you know I
wasn't super thrilled when my family got
a dog but they are obsessed with it is
why despite my own distaste for the
manger Beast I love making my family
happy part of doing that is keeping this
freeloader as healthy as possible which
is why I gave my dog rough greens Dr
Dennis black the founder of rough grains
is focused on improving the health of
every dog in America little did I know
before I got rough grains dog food is
dead food everybody knows that nutrition
isn't Brown it's green well let rough
greens boost your dog's food back to
life rough grains is a supplement that
contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes antiox antioxidants that your
dog needs you don't have to go out and
buy a new dog food you just sprinkle
rough grains on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
grains it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for dogs too Dr Dennis black
is so confident rough greens will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jump start trial bag
so your dog can try it a free jumpstart
trial bug can be at your door in just a
few business days go to
freeruffgreens.com Walsh or call 844
rough 700 that's free Ruff greens.com
Welsh or call 844 rough 700 today
yesterday on the on the members block we
watched this video of a twice divorced
woman explaining why none of the bad
things in her life are her fault let's
watch that again
things I stopped with after my divorce
people who Judge Me based off of my
choices oh you would never get a divorce
no matter what cool well I've had two be
well also stopped with the narrative
that something was wrong with me nothing
is wrong with me things happened to me
that made me the person that I was and
have the struggles that I had you can
fix that anything that you don't like
anything that is no longer serving you
change it
[Music]
change it go to therapy do the
journaling practice meditation do the
things that you need to do to be the
person you want to be
go to therapy she says if we can assume
that she's taken her own advice we see
again how therapy has not helped This
truly awful person be any less awful
if anything it seems to have reinforced
all of her worst attitudes and beliefs
by the way this woman Leah Marie is her
name she is a life coach who specializes
in helping coach women through their own
divorces
the about me on her website says this my
second divorce was the ugliest wake-up
call ever that's when I knew I needed to
do things differently if I was going to
find the happiness I really wanted so I
did all the things therapy journaling
meditation reading books listening to
podcasts I wanted to learn as much as I
could about rebuilding my self-esteem
loving myself taking better care of
myself and knowing my worth
she went to therapy apparently and
discovered that nothing is her fault
that everything is everyone else's fault
that she's been divorced twice and yet
it was something that happened to her
each time not something that she did
or is it fault for
and now she's on a journey of trying to
live the most selfish life she possibly
can by helping other women do the same
by its fruits shall we know uh it and
the fruits as we have seen with therapy
are very rotten indeed now there's a lot
that goes into this many culprits that
could be named a lot driving the problem
but I would like to suggest that part of
the issue is that in many cases not all
but many therapy turns out to be not
only a waste of time but something that
will ultimately do more harm than good
now why might that be the case well for
one thing as is the case with whoever
has been counseling Leah Marie the
divorce coach you know we just launched
a great many therapists and
psychologists and counselors and others
in the psych industry have a deeply and
fundamentally disordered view of
humanity and what constitutes healthy
behavior and good habits of thought and
action
if therapy has any chance of helping you
at all it depends largely on the
assumption that the therapist will have
correct and useful insights into life
and The Human Condition but there is no
license there's no degree there's no
resume there's no credential that
ensures that someone is wise and
insightful much less that they have a
correct understanding of The Human
Condition
and what we find in many cases is that
is that the people in this industry not
only have no special insight into any of
this but in fact are more confused than
half of the people who come to see them
seeking guidance
consider the fact that many people who
declare themselves trans
have this idea first suggested to them
by a therapist or a counselor
this issue alone absolutely proves that
the therapy industry is a disaster most
therapists will not only affirm the
notion that a woman can be trapped in a
man's body but will even suggest it
now
if your problems have nothing to do with
gender and you have your head screwed on
straight enough anyway that you aren't
worried about being coaxed and
developing your own case of dysphoria uh
you know maybe you wonder well uh is is
do I have to worry about this even if
the therapist endorses gender theory is
that a problem for me
but you still have to worry about it
because you have to ask yourself is the
therapist that you're paying an
exorbitant hourly rate to the kind of
person who thinks women can be trapped
in men's bodies and if so this is a
person so delusional so confused so
captured by far left ideology that their
insights cannot possibly be trusted on
any subject at all
and yet the majority of therapists fall
into this category
the pitfalls with therapy don't just lie
with the fact that so many therapists
are bad and stupid
before we can even get to the point of
analyzing the quality of the therapist
we have to deal with the problems
inherent to the very practice of therapy
itself and the biggest one is this that
many people go to therapy simply because
they want to talk about themselves it
feeds their narcissistic impulse to talk
incessantly and think incessantly about
themselves this is the real reason why
therapy is so popular in our culture and
why it becomes more popular with each
generation
it's not that uh mental health is
declining it's that narcissism is
increasing and narcissism is not so much
a mental health problem as a character
flaw
this is primarily what drives the mad
rush to therapy
lots of narcissists who are willing to
pay by the hour just to just to have the
privilege of having a 60-minute block
reserved exclusively to conversation
focused on themselves
but this is exactly the opposite of what
many of these people need
what they need instead is to stop
talking about themselves stop thinking
about themselves stop dwelling on their
own Petty problems stop trying to make
every obstacle they face into some great
Saga of trial and Triumph and instead
just go live their lives with some
humility and sense of perspective
the best advice anyone can give you for
90 of the problems that you bring to a
therapist is this get over yourself and
quit whining go for a jog get a hobby do
something more just don't buy goats do
something more interesting with your
life than than constantly analyzing your
own feelings
your feelings aren't that interesting or
important
are you sad are you stressed out well
welcome to human existence okay that's
part of the bargain not every difficult
emotion or personal experience needs to
be hashed out and analyzed and focused
on
you shouldn't even need to talk about
most of it life is hard yours probably
isn't as hard as you think
if you have enough money to spend 150 an
hour to talk about yourself that
automatically means you have an easier
life than like three billion other
people on the planet I mean there's a
whole family starving to death in a hut
made out of plywood somewhere in the
world uh while you cry to a therapist
that your dad missed your dance recital
when you were seven years old
this doesn't mean that none of your
problems are serious but it does mean
that most of them probably aren't most
of your complaints you should keep to
yourself
and tell no one and move on with your
life
you should have a whole host of worries
and concerns that you have never told
anyone that nobody knows about because
you carry them yourself with quiet
dignity
if you are the sort of person who has
never had a problem you didn't tell
someone about or a complaint you didn't
complain about then therapy is the last
thing you need
except for the therapy I'm giving you
right now the therapy that says grow up
you whine a child
this is what a huge number of therapy
customers need to hear but they won't
hear it because most therapists won't
say it or anything like it
that's because here's the really big
ingrained problem
the therapist's income depends on your
not getting over yourself there is a
conflict of interest here it's the same
conflict of interest every time Apple
releases a new phone you know we know
that the phone is too good if it's too
durable if it works too well if it's too
reliable then you're not going to need
to buy another one for a long time and
that's why they always make sure that
their products will not be durable or
reliable last month the company behind
the instant pot filed for bankruptcy
instant pot was a phenomenon just a few
years ago everyone in the country went
out and bought one now the company's
going under why well the product was too
good everybody bought one and nobody
needed to buy another one because
instant pots work and they stay working
for several years at least the company
made the mistake of creating a well-made
durable product a mistake that not many
companies in America make these days and
even fewer will now
this is also the issue for therapists if
they give you the instant pot version of
therapy if their therapy is useful and
efficient and effective and offers
durable practical long-lasting Solutions
then you're not going to need to come
back every week and pay 150 an hour to
rehash the same issues over and over
again
the therapist will have helped you
become a better more stable more
well-adjusted person but who have lost a
revenue stream at the same time some
therapists a small minority are willing
to make that trade but most are not so
this is where we're left if therapy will
have any chance of helping you at all
the therapist would need to be a very
wise person with a keen understanding of
The Human Condition great moral Insight
enough life experience to serve as a
competent guide whose objective is to
stop whose objective is to stop earning
money
from you okay the good therapist is one
who doesn't want your money anymore
who wants you to get over it and move on
and actually possesses the wisdom skill
intelligence character and insight to
guide you in that direction
now this sort of therapist certainly
does exist they exist out there in the
wild world
but they are very very rare
most come from a more common stock the
sort of therapist who counsels the lost
and confused and narcissistic but is
just as lost confused and narcissistic
as they are
and those are the therapists that are
today cancels hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there